ciao ciao a tutti io sono franco di
pietro e sono uno sprecone se solo uno
sprecone cioè uno che consuma beni senza
discernimento facendone l'uso
scriteriato e o eccessivo sono pessimo
sono di quelli per esempio che fa la
spesa
la metta in frigo poi parte torna a
chissà quando è tutta la spesa nel frigo
ciao ciao per esempio solo per dirne una
ma sapete che c'è sono in ottima
compagnia
purtroppo me ne sono reso conto quando
ho cominciato a prestare attività per
una onlus una onlus che fa una cosa che
fino a poco tempo fa era considerata
illegale pensate ovvero recuperare gli
avanzi di cibo dai catering dagli eventi
dai matrimoni e portarli in beneficenza
il mio primo ritiro è stato
per un evento abbastanza importante una
banca quindi tanto sfarzo tanto cibo
immaginate però sicuramente sfortunato
perché quel giorno c'è lo sciopero dei
mezzi pubblici e da 500 persone che
dovevano esserci se ne presentano meno
di cento immaginate lo sfacelo di cibo
che avanza quel giorno abbiamo ritirato
decine e decine di quei filetti di
fassone che vedete buonissimi li
quintali di finger food è una quantità
di pane che io personalmente nella mia
vita non avevo mai visto tutti insieme
questo
siamo andati con il nostro furgone a
ridistribuire quello che avevamo
recuperato a una mensa che prepara ogni
giorno pasti per persone che hanno
bisogno che ha non hanno un facile
accesso al cibo e riusciamo a dargli
tutto loro super contenti immaginate
però succede una cosa stranissima non
riusciamo a dargli neanche un sacco di
questo pane perché ne avevano già troppo
un'altra onlus a passata prima di noi e
l'aveva già rifilato un sacco
noi allora abbiamo provato in altri due
posti altri due posti dove preparano
centinaia di pasti ogni giorno e la
storia la stessa ce l'hanno rimandato
indietro non l'hanno voluto prendere ne
avevano già troppo e ho cominciato a
chiedermi ma qual è il motivo di questa
incredibile abbondanza è pazzesco non si
riesce neanche a ridistribuire il pane
in beneficenza
sono andato a fare una piccola ricerca
perché non riuscivo a capacitarmi di
questa cosa e ho scoperto questo ho
scoperto che ogni giorno e l'italia
avanza non 1.300 tonnellate di pane se
vi è sembrato tanto il mucchio che avete
visto prima provate a immaginare 1.300
tonnellate sono una montagna
come vedete non sono l'unico a sprecare
sono in ottima compagnia
il problema dello spreco di cibo non si
limita solo al pane e non si limita solo
alle tagli ovviamente
immaginate questo rendetevi conto di
questo che tutta la produzione mondiale
per un terzo viene sprecata non viene
utilizzata per l'alimentazione umana
parliamo di 1,3 miliardi di tonnellate
1,2 trilioni di dollari e la produzione
di cibo da sola impatta per il 10 per
cento dei gas serra di tutto il mondo
questo succede in un mondo in cui
comunque ci sono ancora 800 milioni di
persone che soffrono la fame
una popolazione che sta ancora
continuando a crescere e comunque
risorse limitate per sfamarci tutti il
problema è talmente grande che riguarda
qualsiasi tipo di cibo non solo il pane
vedete qui tutti i cibi più familiari
subiscono la stessa sorte in qualche
punto della catena è talmente grande e
il problema che infatti è la priorità
praticamente numero uno dell'agenda
sostenibile 20 30
l'agenda che ci siamo data dati per
cercare di lasciare un futuro anche alle
prossime generazioni
se guardate praticamente tutti questi
obiettivi hanno a che vedere con la
produzione o il consumo o la
distribuzione del cibo in una maniera
più o meno laterale ma quindi abbiamo un
problema grande come un continente un
agenda ma che cosa viene fatto
effettivamente contro lo spreco
alimentare
beh dicevamo prima sicuramente una delle
prime cose sono le onlus le onlus
certamente fanno un servizio molto buono
di recupero
poi ci sono sicuramente i recuperi per
la zootecnica ovvero l'avanzo diventa
cibo per gli animali
può diventare anche energia si può usare
anche nei biodigestori per esempio per
creare energia alternativa e poi ci sono
tutta una serie di imprenditori di nuova
generazione che stanno cercando
soluzioni innovative ed alla fine di
questo percorso che ho deciso di venire
allo scoperto e fare qualcosa di
concreto si può dire
proprio perché avanza ancora tantissima
roba nonostante tutti questi metodi
quindi si può effettivamente dire che
questa chi di pane quel giorno quella
nota triste in una giornata
effettivamente molto bella siamo stati
l'inizio della mia rivoluzione con la
ragazza che vedete litscher coletta ta
che ho incontrato proprio facendo questi
recuperi
abbiamo deciso di fondare una startup e
di avere dei obiettivi di impatto molto
precisi
innanzitutto lavorare nella diminuzione
degli scarti alimentari proprio prendere
di faccia il problema e procedere un
minore sfruttamento di risorse vergini
con più attenzione ai packaging e
soprattutto con una comunicazione molto
più trasparente ci è venuta un'idea
sostanzialmente con il pane si può fare
un ottima birra
perché il pane può essere usato proprio
in sostituzione del malto d'orzo e
quindi si va a togliere da un mucchio e
si va a non utilizzare materia vergine
per creare un nuovo alimento dagli
scarti della birrificazione che vedete
che è questa granaja di malto d'orzo e
pane che ancora dei principi nutritivi
altissime e molte e molto proteica
facciamo dei prodotti da forno
ovvero stiamo seguendo quella filosofia
che tecnicamente viene chiamata
upcycling dove uno scarto riesce a
diventare un nuovo prodotto oppure una
materia prima può essere utilizzata
anche più volte per scopi diversi come
nel caso della nostra birra e dei
prodotti da panificazione
e cosa abbiamo fatto dal 2021 9
tonnellate di pane recuperato dalla cdo
dai grandi produttori di pane e dai
supermercati
abbiamo creato dei posti di lavoro
abbiamo risparmiato tonnellate di co2
più in virtù dell'utilizzo di un rifiuto
di uno scarto invece che di materia
prima è anche risparmio di spesa
pubblica perché non usare una discarica
comporta un beneficio collettivo
ma quindi anche uno sprecone può fare
qualcosa di concreto contro lo spreco
alimentare
beh sì se prende coscienza dell'essere
uno sprecone e decide che vuole
migliorare che vuole cambiare e ci sono
delle aree di miglioramento
alcune sono personali alcune sono
strutturali alcune sono culturali
innanzitutto bisogna smetterla di
vergognarsi di dire che uno spreca e qua
mi sto riferendo molto ai dirigenti
della gda poco dei grandi produttori di
pane perché se uno cominciasse a
segnalare gli scarti potremmo passare
per prenderli e rigenerarli e
trasformarli in nuovi prodotti ma
soprattutto ci vorrebbe anche un cambio
culturale nel senso che la parola
rifiuto in ambito alimentare dovrebbe
proprio scomparire dovremmo chiamarlo in
un nuovo modo pensate chiamarlo prodotto
da riutilizzare un risorsa da
riutilizzare sembra un cambiamento
banale ma non lo è le parole sono
importanti per l'azione e poi un
cambiamento anche istituzionale come
dicevamo prima se si riuscisse a creare
un sistema premiante per le aziende
che fanno impatto positivo sicuramente
riusciremo tutti a fare un imprenditoria
migliore
e quindi qual è l'inizio del cambiamento
prendere coscienza
siamo degli spreconi siamo degli
spreconi
ma possiamo migliorare
e quindi oggi qui comincio io ciao a
tutti sono franco sono uno sprecone ma
voglio migliorare
[Applauso]